do you know that the average person
checks their cell phone 200 times a day
and when actually they come home from
work cell phone checking increases so
why is that people talk about Internet
addiction let me explain the science
behind us variable ratio and
intermittent reinforcement aspects of
Technology what does that mean it means
that technology in the internet
particularly is like a giant slot
machine every so often you hit something
great you find a great link a great
website every so often you get a
brilliant email praise from your boss or
that text that you've been waiting for
and that is far more addictive than if
every piece of communication was
positive or if every piece was negative
so technology can actually target our
developmental Achilles heel it can it
can elicit negative behavior people call
it Internet addiction I'm not somebody
who believes in Internet addiction why
you cannot be addicted to air you cannot
be addicted to water technology is here
to stay
you would not be able to live or get a
job or survive without at some stage
engaging with technology I'm a cyber
psychologist I couldn't do my job
without access to the Internet so the
thing is it's to learn to modify our
behavior addiction applies an abstinence
model you cannot in this day and age
abstain from technology so I prefer to
think of it in terms of adaptive
behavior technology is a blip in terms
of an anthropological evolutionary a
spectrum
and it has happened so quick that we as
humans are struggling to keep up with
what it offers and how our behavior is
evolving and the negative behaviors that
we see at the moment I like to think of
them as being maladaptive behaviors or
cyber mal adaptive behaviors and the
good news about that is that you can do
something just like learning to stop
biting your nails when you're nervous
you can learn to control your use of
technology technology is here to serve
us not for us to become a slave to it